it does appear doesn't it the Russia is
consolidating its position all the
pro-russian forces are at least in
eastern Ukraine it does and this is the
question for all of us now how long do
we tolerate this it's all part of a
wider Russian strategy they have been
intimidating the smaller countries in
the Baltic States they've got the basin
Kaliningrad there they're in the Baltics
and the Balkans rather with Republic of
Srpska there in the South Caucasus still
with troops in Georgia creating a client
state in Armenia they've annexed Crimea
neither destabilizing the eastern part
of Ukraine but how long do we wait to
react to that your crown of course is
not a member of NATO and there are many
people who feel war-weary and who would
say well this is not our fight really
well and a lot of people would say okay
if we're going to make a stand why
ukraine and why now it's of course about
the Ukrainians and the fact that they
are facing aggression by a large
neighbor with a whole range of new
military hardware but it's also about us
it's about NATO it's about the west and
our willingness to confront this the
Putin problem is basically that he still
has the Soviet concept of a near abroad
in other words that he should have a
veto over the security of course says
it's the European Union there was to
expand these to it well you see it's not
an expansion because in NATO sovereign
three countries were able to join NATO
if they wanted and if they met the
political and military criteria so the
Cold War was about whether free
countries should be able to exercise
self-determination and that's exactly
what's at stake here it is not for
Russia to tell its neighbors what they
can and cannot do free countries must be
allowed to determine their own destiny
for themselves so does that mean being
prepared to fight or doesn't mean
providing lethal supplies to the
Ukrainian forces well we know that the
Russian separatists now have a whole
range of new weapons they've got new
armored vehicles we know that they've
got a lot of drones we know that they've
got very good secure communications so
the Ukrainian forces are largely sitting
ducks that's why they've been able to
make such big advances that's why the
casualties have been so high on the
Ukraine
inside and I think that we have to
ensure that the Ukrainians have what
they need to defend their own territory
they are not the aggressors here and we
have to try to even this up because
while NATO conduct normal exercises the
Russians are using the front line in
Ukraine to test new weapon systems
including the sort of miss anti-air
anti-aircraft system that brought down
our alien economies in terrible state so
this is effectively giving them military
a its is giving them some of the
equipment they will need specifically
unmanned aerial vehicles specifically
anti-tank capability and specifically
very good quality secure communications
we will also have to give them training
because giving equipments not enough you
have to give a capability and it's also
seeing to Russia you know you cannot
keep destabilizing countries on your
borders it is now threatening Europe's
wider security interests we puzzled that
there wasn't a outcome from the meeting
between Angela Merkel and President
Obama yesterday I mean he's been
America's appear to be saying they're in
favor of arming and they appear to row
back from that well I think I think
there's an intention here to send clear
signals to to Moscow that unless they
come up with the ceasefire that's
verifiable sustainable and long-term
then there will be a reaction from the
west to help the Ukrainians I actually
think that there's a case for helping
the Ukrainians anyway because the
ceasefire that we last saw in Minsk back
in September wasn't worth the paper it
was written on Putin went back on every
word that he gave and the question
really has to be us now if he gives
agreement to another ceasefire is it
worth anything at all and should we not
know in the light of that in the light
of the aggression in the light of the
annexation of Crimea be willing to help
Ukrainians isn't the truth though that
the West effectively gave Putin the
green light in as much as both in terms
of politically with the European Union
and militarily with NATO the West
decided they would only offer
Association agreements they wouldn't
offer full membership as they did with a
lot of the other Eastern European
nations well of course they would have
to earn those full membership they have
to have the political structures of a
lake house the legal size it's basically
Georgia and you
don't bother applying and what happened
they were invaded by Russia I think
there's an element of that I also think
it was actually further than Adam
because I think that when the Russians
had a cyberattack on Estonia which is a
NATO member we did nothing and the cut
of Ukraine's gas before which was
against the treaty they invaded Georgie
they still have troops on George and
sovereign territory and through all of
those things and then through his ally
Syria using chemical weapons on his
people we had red lines and didn't react
and i was in washington recently in a
senator said to me I think Putin has
misread the signals I said but I think
he has read them perfectly he prods us
we don't respond and he takes another
step forward so Philip Hammond says a
small-scale conventional war are you
predicting this is going to become a
larger scale conventional war well the
ball is in Russia's court this is a
crisis that was made in the kremlin by
putin it could easily be resolved by
Russia removing its forces removing its
weapon systems from the pro separatist
rebels and actually undertaking a
genuine peace deal but it does not look
to me as though Putin a serious in that
and that bodes ill for us all in the
future unless we're willing at some
point to make a stand and the later we
choose to make that stand the higher the
price is going to be thought Fox thank
you